North Korea's celebrating the newest
advance in its weapons program the north
overnight said it successfully tested a
missile capable of carrying a heavy
nuclear warhead analysts in South Korea
say it flew higher and longer than any
other from the north the country's
seventh missile test of the year was
launched from North Korea's West Coast
yesterday the missile landed in the Sea
of Japan near the Russian coast
Adriana Diaz is in Beijing following the
growing threats and tensions Adriana
good morning good morning North Korea
says the missile was a new model kim
jeong-hoon oversaw the launch and
according to state media he warned that
US territories are within reach and also
claimed that North Korea is capable of a
retaliatory strike the KN 17 missile
lifted off near the country's west coast
reaching an altitude of more than 1,300
miles north korea says the missile was
intentionally fired at a high angle out
of consideration for its neighbors it
traveled more than 400 miles before
splashing down into the Sea of Japan
roughly 60 miles from Russia according
to US intelligence if launched at a
normal trajectory it could have reached
US military bases in Guam international
condemnation was quick South Korea's
newly elected president moon jae-in said
the launch was a reckless provocation
while the White House called for
stronger sanctions and noted the
missiles proximity to Russia saying that
President Donald Trump cannot imagine
that Russia is pleased the timing could
not have been worse for Chinese
President Xi Jinping who's hosting world
leaders including Vladimir Putin at a
global forum in Beijing this morning
Putin called the test counterproductive
and dangerous north korea has tested
dozens of banned missiles in the last
year though this was the first success
after a string of recent failures North
Korea is capable of continuing to
develop longer range missiles physicist
David Wright says the regime's longest
test to date shows they're inching
closer to a missile capable of reaching
the US
and this is an important step there's
still a window for trying to negotiate
with North Korea capping its nuclear and
missile programs at a point where it's
much less of a threat the United States
over the weekend as senior North Korean
official said they're open to talks with
Washington under the right circumstances
echoing a similar statement made by
president Trump but US officials say
that missile launches like this one
shatter the prospect of dialogue at
least any time soon Gayle
Adriana Diaz reporting from Beijing
thank you